foreign
the world needs more hydropower to keep
global warming in check but with viable
sights scarce dam builders are pushing
into high-risk areas nowhere is this
tension more on display than in india's
himalayas
foreign
from the beginning scientists warned
against the site due to its earthquake
and landslide prone location global
warming has only increased these risks
foreign
wind energy in 2013 the project was
damaged along with 30 other hydro dams
from floods and a glacial lake outburst
and last year it was flattened again by
an avalanche that created a deadly flash
flood and claimed more than 200 lives
many of whom were working at the site
thank you
just downstream from tapovan is the 400
megawatt vishnu prayag project it too
suffered damages from the severe
flooding in 2013 and 2021. run of the
river has to be in a remote location
vagaries of nature inhospitable terrain
and all that there's no game saying that
we throw up our hands and just give up
still
india's biggest power producer ntpc is
undeterred by the two natural disasters
in less than a decade and is rebuilding
tapovan as we speak that's because india
is in dire need of hydro as far as the
hydropower projects are concerned
they are the future of our country
the demand for a developing country for
power will keep increasing and unless
supply keeps pace with it the gap
between the two will keep widening
that we cannot afford
at rainy village the closest to the
damaged hydro site
residents are more concerned about
making it through the next rainy season
um
[Music]